you almost have to sit down and go what
would I be needed for right now what
could not happen unless I executed it
yeah it's a good starting point yeah and
that's basically what I did and anything
on that list I then ensured there was a
process system you know whatever it is
in place so that things could happen
without me physically having to sign
anything off I've spent a lot of time
coaching and developing certain members
of my team to give them the confidence
to make decisions I don't stop anything
on the days that I'm not working if I'm
not able to answer the phone for example
hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm your host Hisham
azuz and on this week's episode I was
joined by Lauren weinbank it's fair to
say that she's been dealt her fair share
of adversity since starting her very own
recruitment business in 2018 called Roma
black now she actually started this
business with her co-founder however
along the way it ended up being a
journey that she didn't no longer want
to go on so Lauren found herself
continuing the entrepreneurial Journey
on her own and along the way brought
into the world her two beautiful
children so found herself running a
business on her own whilst being the
mother of two children under two years
old so in this conversation we talk
about how she navigated that how she's
made the business a success how she's
dealt with this adversity how she's
always developed a positive and
optimistic mindset what she would maybe
do differently if she was to start the
journey again and so much more enjoy the
conversation Lauren welcome to the
podcast thanks for having me thanks for
making the trip wasn't too far was it
for you no it's like an hour on the
train so that's right I appreciate the
effort uh regardless thank you um
obviously second attempt this isn't it
yes yeah first time by the way yeah life
got in the way but we're here now so
really looking forward to breaking down
this journey that that you've been on so
like I always uh like to just really
quickly
just to give everyone some immediate
context but since uh the end of 2018
you've been on an entrepreneurial
Journey recruitment entrepreneurial
Journey but before that correct me if
I'm wrong you worked in recruitment for
like three and a half years nearly four
years was that
um yeah about three years yeah roughly
yeah three years then started
um your own recruitment business at the
end of 2018 with your co-founder and
then a year and a couple of months
um from that stop starting point around
Feb 2020
obviously just before covered your
co-founder decided that it wasn't for
her yeah and you then obviously carried
on this business and entrepreneurial
journey by yourself along the way you um
gained investment which we're going to
talk a bit about but today in terms of
where you're on what the business looks
like there's nine of you and then last
year you did just under a million pounds
in Revenue
and we're today going to really focus on
this business generally being on because
I think it's fair to say it has not been
a plane selling ride right there's
definitely been sort of obstacles along
the way which you've worked through and
know that learn from but let's start
with the million pound question
uh would love to hear your thoughts on
what characteristics and traits you
believe make up a highly successful
recruiter in today's market let's start
there yeah okay
um so I think there's like several
things
um
firstly it's the one that everyone says
right resilience is such a up and down
industry that you just have to be able
to take the you know lows of the highs
um and then I think what's sort of
really important is that like focus and
discipline
um a lot of the best recruiters are able
to come in you know stay focused on the
on the job type thing and actually be
consistent there's so many inconsistent
recruiters out there and I think that
comes down to being very process driven
so having you know your day plan mapped
out and sort of sticking to that having
that sort of regimented ability I guess
and I think that's so important so that
you don't get those inconsistent
obviously sometimes it's industry right
market conditions
um but I do think a lot of the
inconsistencies can be avoided
um purely by like being disciplined and
focused on a daily basis yeah I couldn't
agree with you more that is
ties of the Mist in terms of like I
remember when I was in recruitment no
one ever sort of sat me down and said
this is what a good day plan might look
like or yeah you can get better at
prioritizing tasks and it is so
important and what I really like about
thinking
um about thinking about that in terms of
becoming a high performance recruiter is
those things that you just said that are
like entirely in your control yeah your
process your day plan obviously you
still have to do the thing and you have
to perform but there's a lot of things
in recruitment you can't control but
being process driven being disciplined
being focused is absolutely something
you can control on on that then just
just curious really quickly anything
that you've done recently either
yourself or with your team that you
think has enabled Lauren to be
better at being focused disciplined out
of Interest I think
another thing that
it does take I think to be successful is
a long-term mindset in recruitment
because you know that that first sort of
year you work your hardest for the least
amount of money and I think if you can
get your head around that and you can
just focus on relationship building I
think that's something we've heavily
focused on is actually
it might not be right now it might be
six months yeah time you know two years
time like those relationships are key
um because you're always going to need
new clients right
um so I think that's uh something people
massively like
under under rate if you like you know
they they look for the quick wins
um when actually I think if you have
that long-term thinking it can massively
change the game
yeah I I mean I definitely agree I sat
down a common I don't know how you feel
about this and there might have been
your approach during covert but really
common I sat down with
um a lady called uh B who is a contract
recruiter and we're talking about how
she hit some of her achievements and a
really common sentence I've heard a lot
of people say now in line with this is
during covid all I did was speak to
candidates build relationships and
that's all I was focused on and then
when things start to open up or when
things
um yeah started to get back to some sort
of normality
they would then go back to the people
that they actually spoke to or did try
and help them when no one else was
trying to help them yeah so I don't know
like if you've experienced that but I've
heard that so much like all I did was
try to help speak to people build
relationships and then at some point I
haven't had those a lot of those
experiences I've gone look Lauren I
wanted to give you a call because do you
remember when you put on that webinar
around how to stand out when I'm
applying for a job is there any way that
you could help me as I'm hiring for my
team now yeah I think that happens all
the time now when you give value for
free it does come back around
um and when I look back now to when we
like you know with my co-founder we
first set out I think we were naive you
know because you then go from a secure
salary you know decent consistent
commission to you know nothing until the
deals come rolly in
um and you you almost in sort of like
fight or flight mode a bit and I
completely changed my Approach from that
long term thinking I always I'd had that
from day dot starting in recruitment
um and that changed so when I look back
of hindsight now
that's one of the biggest mistakes I
think that I made sort of early on I'm
so glad I managed to pull it back but
yeah so just quickly then just to just
focus on this because I think it'll be
helpful like what does because I'm sure
you helped your team with this now and I
asked someone else's but I think it's
helpful because when you're like in it
you can't see the actions you're doing
today that could be sort of helping you
in six 12 months time it's hard to see
that when you're in it right because you
might have your manager going Lauren we
haven't booked in any interviews this
week you've got putting pressure on
yourself you've got pressures of the
business that you work for so what are
some of the things that you look for or
are the lagging indicators that you
really focus on that gives you
confidence or gives your team confidence
that no you know what if we keep doing
this there's a very good chance that it
will help us in the long run rather than
maybe just the immediate things that we
need to be seeing that can cause more
that short term yeah I don't know if
there's anything that you help your team
sort of really sort of make sure they're
aware of and look at that gives them
confidence that what they are doing is
going to help them in the future because
sometimes that can be hard to see yeah I
think it's a sort of mixture of
approaches in terms of that relationship
building whether it be candidates
clients
um and to look at the value you're
getting from the conversations you're
having and I think if you can see that
someone is putting in the effort and
they're having really good conversations
it just so happens you know that that
client's not hiring right now but the
the you know the conversation's been so
positive that when they are you're going
to stand a chance you know and I think
you can see that in people when you come
we track certain you know noteworthy
conversations you know positive sort of
conversations on LinkedIn
um
that helps to see someone's output and
the passion they have for relationship
building and sort of how successful
based on the outcomes of their
conversations are having
because that's all you're doing when you
first start in Recruitment and I do have
um like trainees you know so people that
haven't ever you know done recruitment
before
so you have to start with the small wins
you can't you know you still track all
the other kpis but you're not going to
have them booking
so many interviews in their first couple
of weeks because that's really for them
to start to build relationships for the
long term yeah a night wherever your
conversations are like that so if I was
to sit down with you and your co-founder
then
at the beginning of this journey and I
said right ladies you're starting a
recruitment business
tell me what you want this business to
be what are your big plans for the
business like how would you talk about
the business in terms of what it would
look like and have them in the period of
time what were the Ambitions if I was to
be sitting in front of you in 2018 and
said tell me about your business what
does it look like what what is it what
were the ambitions
I think this is where we went wrong
um so
I've I'm a really ambitious person and
for me it's almost like it's never and
that's not going to happen it's just
gonna like a when like a matter of time
type thing
um because I'm just very driven and I've
always been like that whereas I think we
were just some very different paths
um obviously I don't know if we'll touch
on this later on but giving context to
that sort of my story if you like
um
soon after setting up the business I
fell pregnant so automatically you know
we are on very different Journeys
um and so I think for me I always saw
the the business being like bigger than
me I didn't want to have to be a slave
to my business because I knew I was
going to have children I knew I wanted
to have the flexibility the freedom
which is why I set up the business in
the first place and I think
Maybe
that's where
it you know it didn't work out for us as
two co-founders you know
um and why she maybe left was just
because
for her she couldn't deal with the
uncertainty
um and probably the fact that we were on
you know different paths yeah
um but I always I think had that
although I didn't have that long-term
mindset when it came to like getting
clients at the very beginning
um I still had it in terms of like where
I saw the business I'm a risk taker so
for me I was like lesson you know let's
get a database let's invest in job
boards LinkedIn
um and we were just very different in
those regards and so I think he
you never know these things when you're
starting out you know you can be friends
you can be colleagues for God knows how
many years but until you work
you know together under that severe
pressure
because you do have no money you know
you have to build something from scratch
that's when sort of the cracks start to
show I think
um and I think it's hard I don't even
know if you could identify it it's just
one of those things you know timing
sometimes is everything and our timing
just wasn't right so just just on this I
know we're very conscious here of like
we don't want to speak for people right
but I think we were we're talking about
this from the perspective of like what
you've learned and what other people can
learn right so I guess what you're
saying that yeah sharing there is like
yeah maybe yeah we weren't on the same
pages and maybe if I asked a question to
you and your co-founding mark got
different answers right which is maybe
why it didn't um quite work out but I
guess from that then looking back or for
other people listening that
do uh someday want to start a business
and don't want to do it on their own
they do want to start with a co-founder
is there anything sort of I guess any
advice around there in terms of like
what you would have maybe done
differently in terms of would you how
would you have more intentionally
understood each other on like what you
did want because it sounds like maybe
you didn't do enough of that or I don't
know
yeah I I think it's really hard to to
pinpoint because there were several
factors right yeah
um
all I know is that that's why I set up
the business you know that was quite
clear from from the outset that that was
my plan to to start a family and have
that flexibility have that freedom to
leave a secure job where
I was being elevated you know I was in a
I was in a good position
um so I think just so it's really
transparent conversations but like often
because things change so not just at the
beginning where you're all in agreement
because it's all fun and exciting she's
just about to start this journey but
actually throughout make sure you've got
that clear communication so that you're
on the same page yeah love that it's
just be I think that's the thing just be
a lot more intentional about it don't
yeah business
um the version one business plan
together and then like never talk about
it again and make sure yeah okay so so
basically Chrome if I'm wrong here but
uh when then you obviously had the
conversation with your co-founder this
was around Feb 2020 right yep and this
is also when so when did you uh when did
you fall pregnant with your first child
September
2018 yeah September 2018. okay
so when you had this conversation
how did he fail
tell me about that conversation because
you must have been like what that I was
pregnant no I know so as in like when
your co-founder I don't know how exactly
how it happened but okay it was like
okay yeah look Lauren I think I'm not
sure this is working out for me
um and by this point you've got another
human in the world yeah
um like yeah how did you feel then when
you obviously realized and learned that
oh okay I'm I'm gonna be uh on this
journey on my own yeah so at that point
so I had my little boy in April we're
now the following year in the February
right and I'm pregnant with my little
girl who's due in the July yeah
um so the cracks had already started to
show right so it it was more of a a
mutual okay
I did I didn't want it for her either
you know because it wasn't right it
wasn't the right timing didn't
bring out the best in her
um and you want you want everyone to be
happy don't you want sort of peace and
uh entrepreneur Journey isn't for
everyone you know it really does come
with its challenges
um so
my initial
reaction was almost like you know
I've now gonna have two kids and a
business that I've got to run on my own
you know how am I gonna do it
um but also
it was almost like I knew I would get
through it if that makes sense I had
that sort of self-belief so it was a bit
of excitement of like okay what does
this next chapter look like for me on my
own or you know whatever pathway was
going to be in front of me so where like
what I love about this is a lot of
people
wouldn't react like that so like you
just curious like where have you
developed this mindset has it been
over time like can you pinpoint it
anywhere like where have you developed
this mindset of being able to focus on
the things that you can control not sort
of getting swept away with all the
emotions of like hell I've got
yeah now two children to take care of
and
um make sure I can provide for them
yeah how have you gone about developing
this mindset of yours yeah do you know
what I don't really know I don't really
know
um I'm a really sort of calm
collected person so I don't let a lot of
things like I get stressed right that's
that's natural but I don't let a lot of
things get on top of me
um and I'm just positive I'm optimistic
so I always think it's gonna work out
it's you know this has happened for a
reason it's gonna work out
um
my mum has always sort of drummed into
me like don't let things that you can't
control
your yeah yeah effectually control your
your emotions
um because you can't change it so if you
can't change it why dwell on it
um but yeah I don't know where sort of
that
like I mean if your mom was telling that
that definitely would have a factor yeah
it would but at the same time when I
told them that I was going to set up the
business they were like no why you know
you've just got promoted and you've run
a really good sort of like upward
trajectory there why would you do that
um
but I've just I've just always had that
sort of like fire in me to to do my own
thing
um which I guess is what I did so what
was what was the game plan then from
sort of February time so had your little
go in April to two months so I had her
in four months old I had her in July oh
sorry July so that was July 2020. yeah
so leading up to that then what was the
game plan was like right let's get some
deals in or was this I can't remember
the the timeline but or was that like
did you uh get investment before you had
your daughter or was it around that time
or
um so
I was again timings everything
um I was lucky in that
some of the clients that I'd been sort
of actively pursuing had come to
fruition so I managed to have I think it
was like a 50k month
um in the March and that was like just
by yourself yeah let's go so the first
luck proper month on your own yeah okay
month yeah cheers
um so that sort of kept me going because
I thought well I'm gonna you know I'll
give you some good fun to have another
baby yeah not be able to just like be
recruiting five days a week
um so there was an opportunity that sort
of presented itself
um for
uh company for me to go and do their
internal Recruitment and kind of like
head it up
but I knew that I didn't want to you
know like abandon Roma black I still
very much believed in it even given sort
of the the situation I was in
um and that conversation just evolved
um I don't really know how we how we got
there but maybe they saw something in me
and then I ended up uh getting
investment which enabled me to build a
team so
um I could actually have that sort of
balance of being a mum and my business
still sort of running because yeah at
that point in time I I wouldn't have
been able to to juggle that really I
know with a one-year-old and a newborn
I think trying to speak to candidates
you know build build a client base yeah
I don't think that would have been been
doable so this was so
um let me know if this is all correct
right so just for people's contacts here
so yeah the so basically you raised 250
Grand
and then they obviously have equity in
in your business and then that enabled
you to yeah hire two people and they
started in September yeah so I hired two
that started in September
um both times with with both my kids
personal choice I was you know back into
it within three months
um sort of not full time obviously but
sort of part-time
um and at that point we then had a
little office it's like the three of us
um and so I'd sort of go in two days a
week
um yeah I think my little girl was like
12 weeks or something at this point
um and I think you didn't think she was
that old to be fair and uh yeah then
come the sort of the next year
um we hired more people
um and we just sort of continued sort of
that growth journey I guess from those
first two hires and then basically and
then the the deal was basically ended up
being 50 50 Partners right
so this was actually a client
um no it wasn't a client it was someone
that just wanted me to go and like be
their head of recruitment if you like
like head up their recruitment function
right
um and so that conversation they then
took it to the founder and said maybe
this is a investment opportunity for you
yeah um what do you think they saw a new
then
maybe just my my like passion and drive
and you know the fact that
I did have two kids but I was still very
much you know like moving forward and I
think maybe that work ethic that's so
important
um even when you come back to sort of
successful traits of recruiters work
ethic is huge
when I look at my best recruiters
they've got an exceptional work ethic
so we had um
an amazing lady called Hannah Ahmed on
the podcast who was really sort of open
and vulnerable with us and spoke about
her journey with postnatal depression
yeah
and she had an unplanned pregnancy she
has her own recruitment business
the pregnancy didn't quite go to plan in
terms of didn't have a natural birth and
these types of things so like let's just
talk about this for a second because you
sort of you talk about having two
children with a bit of a smile on your
face a bit of a laugh just like that
would be so difficult so like
let's just talk about that for a second
like
what like how did you I don't know how
did you juggle things what was the
mindset because I feel like again this
comes back to your mindset of folk and
focusing on things you can control like
yeah how what was the thought process to
go you know what I'm going to show up
I'm still going to achieve the things
that I'm going to and this isn't yeah
going to be the reason why I can't
achieve my goals and I don't know like
what was the thought process yeah I just
didn't see any barriers to entry the
fact that just because I'm a mum now
like I can't run a successful business
and you know a lot of people there were
a lot of judgments But ultimately you
know I was on my own Journey like you do
you I'll do me you know
um when you said judgments what do you
mean well just like going back to work
you know a lot of people take nine
months off a year off
um I didn't have that luxury you know
and actually that's it it brings me
happiness my children bring me happiness
but my work brings me happiness so I
didn't wanna
like abandon that um and I was just
really lucky that you know I've got a
really good support system around me uh
good grandparents
um family's been really helpful yeah so
I had that sort of child care support on
the days I would go into the office to
start to
build out essentially the the business
you know as a small team hey everyone a
real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry and
Source breaker because you listen to
this podcast you were able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products
uh and then like obviously now in
today's world we love talking about
balance right I just think I don't know
how I feel I almost feel like it's sort
of unrealistic I think it is important
for you to be self-aware and understand
like is sort of Lauren burn in the wick
at both ends and what can I do to make
sure that I don't arrive at this
destination of being like I'm absolutely
like obviously we don't want to
get there but in terms of like
like yeah in those moments Lauren been
like people going on you haven't really
got work-life balance and you're like
well how can I do that you know
I mean like one minute I'm feeding the
kids and they're relying on me and then
I'm trying to do deals and build
relationships with clients so how how
did you approach that that balance
element then like how would you approach
that in terms of Lauren having the
working entrepreneur hat on then having
the mum hat on how did you balance it
yeah so I honestly don't know how like
I've got a friend she's got three girls
under four wow and she still like
recruits herself
for me again it comes back to I saw a
bigger picture for myself where the
business almost
didn't need me to run and on the early
days of you know the small team that
didn't happen like balance I feel like
it can be defined as like different
things but I get what you're saying you
know I don't believe there is true
balance because if you're really
excelling in one area in your life
something else is suffering as a
consequence
um so the the way I maintained balance
was by having set days that I'd go in
and I'd work
um and then days I had my kids but
ultimately there were days when I'd be
taking calls from my team or clients or
you know and I haven't actually
recruited myself now for maybe like two
and a half years oh really
um so that enabled me to have the
balance and I now have a leadership team
in place so if I've got my days of the
kids now
my phone doesn't ring um
um but I took a while to get there you
know so you can have the balance in
terms of that home work life split but
ultimately if you if you want to be
truly successful those scales gonna tip
yeah no I definitely agree so let's talk
about how you got to that point because
that's pretty well I speak to business
owners all the time and are of similar
size to where you are now nine people
um sometimes even bigger and the owner
is still very much reliant on and
dependent on so
how have you like talked me through how
you've got to that point obviously you
said it was difficult to get there yeah
obviously it requires having people in
the right seats but how did you
intentionally get to that point of Laura
not being dependent on for Roma black to
to be successful and to be hitting the
the goals that you wanted to talk to us
a bit about how you approached that
yeah so yeah like I said it's been
a bit of money
I knew that was like my end goal so that
I was still you know needed in the
business and I still added value to the
business but it would run
smoothly you know without me on on the
days that I needed it to run without me
and that's obviously then just evolved
to the point where
it is pretty self-sufficient now
um I still work in the business I still
work on the business
um three days a week
um in terms of me physically in an
office
but I work all the time because I love
it it doesn't feel like work so if I'm
sat there and I put the kids to bed
and I'm doing a bit of Business
Development or you know that's sort of
really a key role that I still play very
much in the business
um new client attraction things like
that
um
I think the the journey was firstly
stepping away from that day to day
which
all I did was change my efforts from
being focused on that sort of 360 to
then just the business development so
it'd almost just be like feeding my team
if you like
um and also had 360 Recruiters in the
business who would bring on their own
clients too
and I think then what's
slowly happened is for me to hire the
right people into the business who have
the same mindset as me are really
aligned with where I want to take the
business
who can
you know help it to to get to probably
even where I can get it to so what I've
tried to do is build a team that are
better than me
to take their business to new levels
love that what's been just had um
Roger sat down here we spoke a lot
around leadership and how I don't know
sort of if you've had your own
experiences of this maybe at Roma black
or before but obviously a lot of people
find themselves in a sort of management
leadership role simply because
uh Lauren was a top performer right and
uh for no thought of their own I think a
lot of the time like a lot of this time
these people don't actually get much
help or support on how can Lauren become
not in your top performer but a great
leader
like what's been what's been your
journey with with leadership and sort of
enabling to and um yeah getting the best
out of people and then most importantly
for you for you to be self um the
business to be self-sufficient or
reliant on you these management leaders
need to be great managers and leaders
right yeah so how how do you approached
that for yourself and then have you
enabled the team to be people that don't
just tell people to do things but coach
people and get the best out of people
what's been in relationship with
leadership yeah so
early on when I started in recruitment I
was
highlighted as someone they wanted to
Fast Track to management
um so I think it was actually the first
person to ever skip every single like uh
promotion like senior lead and I went
straight to managing consultant
um Looking Back Now
I feel like
I probably didn't develop as a recruiter
as much because I've then thrown into
being a recruiter but also being a
manager still quite early on you know in
my recruitment Journey if you like
um and you just sort of learn don't you
how to work with different people
um I don't even think it's like managing
people it's like working with different
people
um and getting knowing how to get the
best out of those individuals so I guess
once I then
had my own business and was you know
hiring my own team I learned so many
lessons you know along the way like no
one gets it perfect first time round
um and I think it's about
from observing I guess previous managers
that maybe I've had not being like
emotionally driven so you know if like
something goes wrong and then they're
like taken out on the whole team they've
pulled everyone in like it's an
emotional reaction so I've always put
time in between anything so saying does
go wrong or something hasn't like gone
to plan
someone's you know not performed or you
know dumb something
just taking that time and delivering
messages in the right way like we're all
people I really don't believe in sort of
that old management approach where like
you don't hit your kpis you're like
dragged in or
I told off in front of other people like
I'm just like I said I'm a very calm
person and I really like to coach people
I like to try and add value I like to
listen
um and help like develop individuals you
know have I got it wrong hiring certain
people along the road absolutely like be
surprised if anyone didn't
um but I have got to a point now where
I've got a really strong team that are
super passionate really respectful
um we just work really well together and
I've then tried to sort of instill those
same sort of characteristics I guess
um into my leadership team we're all
very different
um
But ultimately you just want to get the
best out of people I know one person is
the same so you need to bend you know to
find out what their values are and what
drives them
um because not everyone in recruitment
is like driven by the same thing that's
something I've massively I've learned
like not everyone is actually really
driven by the money some of them are
driven by the achievement of their
target for the business that they're
working in as opposed to the money in
their pocket have you got better at
uncovering that do you really try and
make sure you sort of dig into that on a
consistent basis yeah so we've actually
just undergone like a strengths
assessment okay which is really really
valuable I'd done it myself and thought
yeah this be incredible to do as a team
so we looked at our individual strengths
and then our strengths as a collective
nice
um and it really sort of highlights
people's True Values and like drivers
and why they are the way they are you
know why maybe some are really process
driven
um why some are more driven by like
competition which I think helps then you
effectively
um coach the people that you have in
your business and get the best out of
them so what how does that work and
there's like a series of questions or
yeah it's a series of questions at a
time so you almost have to go with like
your like yeah yeah and then it produces
a report of like your top five strengths
okay so what would be like an example of
Australian what sort of things so like
my number one strength you're gonna ask
me like don't ask me all five because
my number one strength is futuristic
okay which means that I yeah
continuously sort of look to the future
but sort of bring others
um yeah love that so I think this would
be like I saw that
this might have been part of it I don't
know but I saw that you uh invested in a
career coach yep best decision you've
ever made yeah one off yeah taught me
about that talk to me about that so
I'm currently on my second coach okay
um so first one was really to help me
get to the point where the business
was self-sustained like man you know I
was literally running without me and so
processes systems you know the right
people
um and that was transformative
um and then I've recently just started
coaching with
um a new coach that will help me more as
a leader
um and what what does that relationship
like are you like
um is it like a weekly thing is it a
monthly thing are you monthly but that's
that's literally brand new really yeah
how why did you end up going down that
path I'll proper rate that I think
that's that's brilliant big on
self-development and I think one of the
biggest things
and learning curves is self-awareness
and I like to think I'm I'm pretty
self-aware so if someone said something
to me I'd probably go oh yeah do you
know what I do do that um
um but some people don't have that
self-awareness and so I think through
sort of self-development you get to
unpick a lot of things
um to find out and that's why I love
that strengths assessment like why am I
the way I am type thing why are these my
leading strengths
um and it's just so interesting because
apparently people that sort of do work
that leans into their strengths are way
happier way more fulfilled
um and when I looked at my strengths
recruitment is so aligned to what my
strengths are
um so yeah I'd urge anyone to to take
that assessment because it's really
valuable how did you go about finding
the right coach because
you get you get pepper don't you and
like there's so many coaches now
um like I've been I sort of said to them
to like stop calling because it wasn't
the right time but like I've been
getting calls from like this action
coach now from free coaching sessions
and it's like you know I mean it can be
a bit of a bit of a black hole yeah did
you get recommended how did that happen
so I think there's so many coaches out
there now isn't there yeah especially
sort of like on LinkedIn
um but I'm more driven by so the reason
that I went with my first coach was
because I could see that she'd built a
business
also it had you know two children and
built a business with Zero's investment
which is like incredible yeah
um and the business completely ran
without her in it and I think for me to
try and
create if that balance exists
um to get to that point so that I really
didn't feel like I was being constantly
torn or at one point you know something
was that the scales were sort of tipped
um I wanted to dig deeper to what can I
do what can I
um what processes or systems can I
Implement so the business runs you know
smoother
um with or without me and in this case I
went with without me
um even though I'm still very much in
the business right but it was just like
you're not making it not dependent on
you yes yeah
um so it sounds like you found you found
someone that resonated with you yeah
that you could see someone yourself in
yeah that maybe are like a couple of
steps ahead then like where you are
today yeah so yeah that's a quite good
like I think yeah that's if I like I'm
definitely open to investing in a coach
in these things and that they're the
sort of things that I'd look for because
yeah I think it always helps if you're
speaking to someone that you you think
has been in your shoes I don't know it
just feels like what you're able to get
access to is just going to be a lot more
credible
and it's ultimately I think you need to
align it with your goals so that was one
of my goals I could I could see someone
that had achieved what I wanted to
achieve
that her business ran you know without
her in it um again she still was sort of
working in it to a you know small degree
if you like
um so I would never coach with someone
that's approached me
um
like I'm way more
I don't know I'm like I really think
things through before I do them before I
act so
only a thing really sort of resonates
with me will I right then approach
someone to be like do you know what that
feels like the right natural step for my
own self-development
um and the current coach I actually met
um one of the ladies that works with
this coaching company at the women in
business and Tech event okay
um and they're exceptional like
industry leaders within the tech space
have then gone on to like their tagline
it's like enabling dreams nice
um and one of their coaches I got
introduced to and she she's just
incredible like I can't even tell you
and she's coached all of the top you
know industry leaders in all of the
biggest companies at a global level
um and so for me I thought to really
take it to the next level I want to be
coached by someone who is exceptional at
leadership
um and her
questioning
like to get the best out of people to
ask clever questions to really unpack
someone so that you can sort of get to
the bottom of something if you like
um
she's like just brilliant yeah
so just just quickly because I think
this will be helpful for people
particularly the way that you're
describing how much of uh like you said
obviously multiple times that the
business isn't relying on you so what
have been some of like the game changing
processes that you've implemented then
that you think has really enabled that
we've spoken about obviously making good
hires having a leadership team but what
are there any so yeah what sort of
processes have you implemented do you
think that have really enabled you to
yeah not be dependent on yeah so I think
it's it's like several things so even
down to like the operations of the
business like have someone have someone
running that right so if there's you
almost have to sit down and go
what would I be needed for right now
what could not happen unless I executed
it okay it's a good starting point yeah
and that's basically what I did and
anything on that list I then ensured
there was a process system you know
whatever it is in place so that
things could happen without me
physically having to sign anything off
or you know so say
um when it comes to terms of business
like that that's someone else now that
that does that you know I don't I don't
need to approve
times a visit that's all dealt with of
the leadership team
um and
I guess the biggest sort of like
difference in where I was maybe a year
ago to where I am now maybe even six
months to be fair
um was that on my days off with the kids
I'd be getting phone calls oh um just
got off the phone with you know this you
know blah blah what do you think what do
I need to do and so I've I've spent a
lot of time coaching and developing
certain members of my team to give them
the confidence to make decisions
um because when it's not your business
and I can understand this right
um You don't want to make the wrong
decision or do the wrong thing or you
know if you've got a counter offer or
whatever it is
um everyone would come to me
um you know what would you do and
everything else and so I've just almost
created layers so that
nothing
I don't stop anything on the days that
I'm not working I don't stop anything
from happening if I'm not able to answer
the phone for example so where'd you
even start with that then because like
so many people will be in that position
I feel like where they always get calls
oh Lauren I just feel like I'm really
sorry to bother you like can you just
help me with this yeah like do you just
initially start by communique I don't
know like how do you set boundaries yeah
yeah that's like me I've set boundaries
you have to set boundaries
um and I'm really lucky right that I'm
so transparent with my team um so it's
not that I don't work hard because I'm
always like I say I'm always working
um and I think that that's one of the
biggest things that
um people like perceive because people
see what they want to see don't they and
they don't see what happens behind
closed doors
um is that oh God how hard can it be
coming in two days a week you know and
it's like you have no idea like I work
all the time
um I'm just not in the office right
um and so it comes firstly by
surrounding yourself with a team who
respects you who respect those
boundaries who know you're doing
absolutely everything to drive that
business forward
you know that you give value you know
where it's needed
um and ultimately if someone really
needed me I'm going to answer the phone
right but unless it was like life or
death they wouldn't call me now because
I don't need to
um so
yeah I I think that you need the right
people you need that communication to
begin with to set boundaries look these
are the days that I'm and it's probably
most helpful to say like women that are
trying to
like spend time with their kids but also
like keep their business afloat if
they've got a team as well
um and it's just having that sort of
clear communication set in the
boundaries right these are the days that
I'm with my kids I want to give my all
to them on the days I'm with them so
you know sort of yeah unless there's
this this scenario and you always have
to start with that and then start yeah
slowly come away from it and give them
the confidence to deal with any
situations
so I've got one of your
uh post here
so I think we've covered quite a lot of
this bit if there's anything that maybe
you want to add now whatever it was
around
um Roman black timing for when you put
if you're starting your own business
here's what I wish someone had told me
year one would put pick your team wisely
spoken a lot about that no your value
take time to reflect and celebrate trust
the journey stay in your lane don't be a
slave to your business which like you're
saying hire people better than you
yeah anything else would add to that or
are we pretty happy with
that list yeah
um
do you know what there's probably so
many
so many
um
if long-term mindset's not on there then
keep that long-term mindset because it's
quite easy to come away from it
um especially if you know
your jobs have dried up and you're
starting to that the Panic starts to set
in you start to I think come away from
your like
like how the core way that you work
um so just trying to keep that long-term
mindset and that positivity that
optimism
um
and also
I think if you do have a team just
really looking at your your culture and
what you can do to always sort of
positively influence that
um because there's a lot of women that
don't go into certain industries because
they feel like they're not going to get
that balance when actually my top
performer Works four days a week
if it's half term she she's still
working she'll take it's holiday right
she's still working and she just works
around our kids like I don't have to
worry she's so like intrinsically driven
that she's gonna work her ass off
um so a lot of companies I think just
need to
give that flexibility and they'll be
surprised that some of their best
workers will be women with with kids
yeah fair I want to ask you about that
clearly a passion of yours but I I think
on that list what I I don't know from
what I've got outside looking in and I
want to hear your take on it like
how much like you've really built your
brand I feel like on online or you
you're definitely consistent so
surprised not to see building your brand
on there because how much has building
your brand impacted the business or what
sort of positive effects have you seen
from building your brand because you you
are pretty consistent with sharing
content and building a brand on LinkedIn
I'd say yeah do you know what that's
probably that's a big one that's that's
missed
um and I really wish I was one of those
people when I like started Roma black
you'll never catch me posting on
LinkedIn yeah because I'm quite a
private person and I think that I was so
set in my ways with that that I
swear to God I wish if there's one thing
that I'd have invested in that back then
um because everyone's on LinkedIn now
everyone's building a personal brand
back then they weren't
um but it's one of those things isn't it
like what made you start insights what
changed it
I think just seeing
the success stories other people were
posting about their personal brand and
what what doors had opened and I can
absolutely I could test that now like it
has open doors for me
do you think
um probably
like a year ago oh wow okay yeah
um
but inconsistently yeah so probably say
the last of like six months I've tried
to be a lot more consistent yeah so what
sort of doors have opened up for you
then what have been some of the positive
stories that you've experienced just
like even people that send you messages
you know that that want advice and
coaching to build their recruitment
business new clients you know just like
new relationships
on a global level uh it's just it is
incredible what can come from a personal
brand and that's why if you look at any
of my team they're all over LinkedIn
they're all building personal Brands
um because there's so much value in it
and I think some companies
especially if you maybe rewind like four
years ago
would see that as a threat
um yeah
yeah but if you really have a great team
and they're happy then you don't have
don't have to worry to be vulnerable for
your team that's just part of the game
it's life right and if someone was
presented with an exceptional
opportunity that I can offer someone I'd
be annoyed if they didn't take it yeah
you wanna again come back to focus on
what you can control you can focus on
creating a culture that people really
happy to be part of and they're being
supported they're the things you can
control yeah and I think um
like different trading and between like
your company brand and your personal
brand I've probably spent a lot of time
focusing on like the company brand and
not my personal brand
um whereas now it's like the two
black side by side yeah so if if uh I
was sitting in front of you right now
and I was Lauren when I was going there
you over catch me and post something
because you might have people in your
business now that you have to really
convert like yeah yeah and there'll be
people listening to this still like
scared of posting don't want to post
don't want to be
someone that just adds another selfie to
the news feed yeah talk like how are you
convincing me what sort of like what
what's your advice to me or what things
would you talk to me about as to like
why you think it's worth my time as a
recruiter in today's market yeah I think
the biggest thing is
we're so like society and like Instagram
everyone's driven by likes or comments
and I think if you can get your head
around look I might post something and
it might get one like but ultimately I
only needs to get that one like and it's
reached you know
even a really low scale 100 people or
one of those 100 people might be a
client that's hiring that's just seen
your post so I think it's a like it's
like exceptional opportunity for
recruiters to position themselves as an
industry expert if they are you know
connect with candidates potential
clients
um because that's what like everyone is
and
cold calling has its place right
but
sometimes it's a long-winded way of
trying to get through to someone there's
so many other avenues by using LinkedIn
where you can reach a wider audience so
I think it's definitely worth people's
time and it's just getting over the fact
that okay it's gonna take me a while
it's like when that you first got
Facebook or something or first got
Instagram and you get that one like on
you on your picture like it can only go
up it can only grow from here so just to
have that kind of mindset I can only
build got to start somewhere even you
know
the biggest content creators on LinkedIn
would have started somewhere yeah and I
know
this sort of stat came out today but I
know you said it is a lot more
competitive than it is but still what uh
there's a stat there that people love
people saying which is like two percent
of LinkedIn users on your post weekly or
whatever so I don't I feel like that's
that stat has been around long enough
now where I feel like it's got to be
more than two percent but I do still
think maybe 20. yeah I do still think
like I couldn't agree with you more like
recruitment is is is competitive
and it's like for me it's just more
about giving yourself more or more ways
to connect with people and at the end of
the day like we're all human and yes
it's B2B but for me it's it's human to
human really and if you uh have another
way to Showcase who you are what you're
about but like you said most importantly
showcase your credibility and what you
know about the market and these types of
things it's only going to help the rest
of your activity if that's in mailing if
that's dropping people a message if
that's calling people if that's emailing
people it for me it's just an it's just
an absolute no-brainer it has to be
non-negotiable now yeah and it puts a
face to a name doesn't it and it almost
like we are all human and it gives that
human element like for people to see
your achievements or you know what
drives you or and you know that's so
funny about that stat because I have a
lot of you know even like clients that I
don't work with them anymore right my
team do
um and I still talk to them and they'll
message I just love following your
journey but they would have liked like I
wouldn't have noticed that I like my
life story do you know what I mean I
never know yeah yeah she's only like
lurkers on there you know I actually
spoke to a lady the other day and she's
like oh yeah I'm a lurker on here I was
like I love being amazing I was like I
love that like I love the honesty but it
is true there are probably so many
people that just watch you know from
afar they never post but they're but
they're there and they can see anything
and it only takes for your post to just
trigger timing as everything in
recruitment so why not get out there
every day it's like doesn't take a lot
of time for sure so look as we come to
the end here then something that I know
you're passionate about you've mentioned
it a few times
female leaders inspiring the future
female leaders how how can we create
more female recruitment leaders like
talk to me about that your sort of
thought process on that your mindset
towards that yeah I think the no-brainer
is what I touched on earlier is to give
women more flexibility so they don't
feel like they have to choose between
like between their career and like and
having a family yeah because for me when
I was thinking right you know I'm gonna
I'm gonna set up on my own
um
I there was like it was very sort of
male dominant in terms of their managers
and directors and so it was very much
like oh you don't need to have kids yet
you know have them in your 30s like you
know you've got a good thing going on
here and so I saw those signs very early
and I thought if I'm gonna have true
flexibility and freedom I'm gonna have
to set up on my own which is what I did
um so if people can
give women the platform and not see oh
what if their kids are sick or also what
if they are you know they're still going
to work their ass off
you know that I do feel like
and I can't speak for everyone but women
do work exceptionally hard and they're
very good at multitasking they're very
good at time management so they don't
need to be physically visible five days
a week in the office because they're
probably still outperform people that
are you know first ones in last ones out
because they're just smarter with their
time
um and yeah so I think if we can educate
and create more flexibility for women
then more women will get to leadership
because they'll enter markets that you
know has the the platform for them to to
thrive and actually do their best work
[Music]
yeah it's hard isn't it because I always
sort of think of this
um saying or quote whatever is like you
you can't be what you can't see and it's
like if you're a female right now in a
recruitment business and you know deep
down you're on a family and there's no
one at director or whatever that has a
family and they've had both you like how
are you not going to think that it's not
possible or that you are going to have
to sacrifice your career Ambitions uh
for your family yeah so does it is it
just more is it just more about than do
you think like just
um yeah a bit having the the courage to
have the conversation and
yeah it's it's hard right because look
you're a business owner now let's be
honest if
you interview someone and I go yeah I
really want a family there's no way
you're not going to think about that
do you know I mean in terms of like Okay
so she could work for us for a bit then
she sort of maternity leave yeah it's
hard right because it's like even
speaking to my partner about now we we
definitely have a family and it's it's
hard like how do you approach it
like do I tell them I want to have a
family I don't want to think that I'm
going to work there for a couple of
months and then I'm going to be having a
child and then I'm on my it's hard isn't
it to have the courage from a male
standpoint to talk about it and go no no
we will support you for a woman to go I
do really want a family and own that
without them not thinking oh what are
they gonna think are they gonna think
I'm not it's hard isn't it yeah and it
is and I think it's a societal mindset
shift you know it's not a thing that's
ever going to change overnight because
some people are incredibly set in their
ways of
oh you know we're gonna train her up and
she's you know and then she's gonna go
off yeah but we'll she'll be back you
know if you create that culture and you
create the opportunity where she can
have that flexible working she'll be
back if you don't she won't because it's
not feasible
um so in order to have that
representation in leadership
um females or families
you know men with families are Maybe
like more more of a caregiver type thing
than the female sometimes you get that
um then
it's going to start with those small
changes
further down to give that flexibility so
people can actually get there
and just cure it before we come to the
end here just super curious and then
what you've seen there might be things
that you've looked at
with your recent business around female
leadership and stuff what is like
a dire maternity cover or support like
what is absolutely terrible
I don't know I can't really tell you
because like I didn't have like I worked
for myself right so I didn't have a
maternity
um cover or support yeah yeah and I went
straight back to work
um and that's personal choice
um but I think that it's a real tricky
one because when you look at
you know start-up companies
they can't offer what the Facebooks
exactly can offer but ultimately you
have to know that
when you're selecting your employer that
that does fall on on the on the female
right
um and
I think it's then about going okay we
know we wanna
have a baby so let's start saving if my
company don't have the best maternity
policy because there are they're a
startup or they're a small business
um and yeah I I think that that's more
of a consideration because it's gonna
take a long time until there's and
obviously there's the changes with child
care yeah what was that I can't fully
understand that um so I don't think it's
till 2025 but right now it's you get 30
hours
um and what they're trying to do is
basically create more funding so it's
like 30 hours a week so basically women
can get back into work because the
biggest is the cost of childcare yeah
um so like my child care bill that's a
good thing I guess oh it's a massively
positive thing yeah
um because it means that more women can
return to work because what they're
faced with is well I could go to work
but it just clears my child care bill so
I might as well yeah
um so hopefully that will see a natural
shift for more females
um at least having the choice or more
yeah rather than just thinking like you
just said like that isn't very
empowering is it to be like no I could
even stay at home and like I get covered
or yeah I'll go to work and I don't see
my kids and I'll just get paid just as
much like yeah it all goes on channel
yeah
I think that's what's so great about
recruitment is if you can have that
flexibility
you have that OTE
so it's almost like even if you do have
child care costs you've got those on top
earnings to really sort of make it worth
it especially if you then get the
flexibility so that if your you know
child's ill or it's half term or
whatever you're not having to use
holiday the fact that your child's not
very well yeah that's just yeah yeah so
look let's end it then you're a futurist
talk to us about what you're excited is
that what is that what you said right
yeah yeah uh I thought I'd made that
word up then
that's one of your strengths so what
what are you excited about what is what
is what does the rest of this year look
like what what have you got top of mind
yes I'm excited to just continue to
build Roma black
um you know we've really got ambitious
plans in terms of global client base
um and
got a really solid team so I'm just
incredibly excited to continue to sort
of build that out and become even more
of a solid team invest more in the
people
um and then also with my other business
tribe which is all about
um empowering females in Tech through
sort of coaching mentoring
um online resources Community
um that launched yesterday so just
excited to go on that Journey as well
love it I let Lauren thank you so much
coming on the podcast absolutely love
your optimism I'll put it mindset I
think you've been on a fantastic journey
and uh yeah like we will inspire a lot
of people I just love the fact that yeah
had plenty of obstacles along the way
but pushed on learn from them yeah and
yeah I'm not surprised that you're
excited uh with where you're going so
thank you so much thank you thank you so
much for listening to the episode I hope
you enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode
side
all right